cela fait maintenant un an que la
pandémie de kobe de 19 a débuté et
malheureusement comme l'avaient anticipé
les chercheurs de l'impérial college en
mars dernier les vagues et les
confinements s'enchaînent pour éviter
des surcharges des services hospitaliers
après les confinements de mars et de
novembre il semble qu'il fait maintenant
envisager un risque de 3e confinement en
janvier ou en février pour mettre un
terme à ces vagues douloureuse aussi
bien sur le plan social et économique
qu'en termes de santé mentale pour
l'ensemble des populations et pour
rétablir durablement plus de liberté il
semble urgent d'adopter des solutions
efficaces contre le coc vite 19 et comme
annoncé dès le début de cette pandémie
seuls des vaccins suffisamment efficaces
peuvent espérer être des solutions
durables
or ça tombe bien plusieurs vaccins
contre le coc vide 19 ont été
développées testée et prouvée et surtout
approuvé par les agences de sécurité
médicale de vaccins en particulier
sortent du lot à savoir les vaccins de
la collaboration fit for you and takes
d'un côté et de l'entreprise moderne de
l'autre ces deux vaccins ont la
particularité d'être des vaccins à arn
on verra dans quelques minutes ce que
cela signifie quoi qu'il en soit de
façon remarquable ces deux vaccins ont
des taux d'efficacité de 90 à 95% ce qui
est très au delà des efficacités
attendue par les experts du domaine et
ont pour l'instant après des millions de
vaccinations soulevé aucune alerte
préoccupante d'effets secondaires
dangereux
il s'agit là d'une excellente nouvelle
très inattendu célébré par de nombreux
experts qui permet d'augmenter
grandement notre optimisme vis-à-vis de
l'année 2021 à venir
il ya quelques mois
accent arn ont été testés sur une
population de dizaines de milliers de
volontaires pour tester ce vaccin on
assigne les volontaires au hasard dans
un des deux groupes pour le premier
groupe appelé groupe contrôle on injecte
un placebo pour le second groupe appelé
groupe tests on injecte le vaccin et
tout ceci s'est fait en double aveugle
ce qui veut dire que ni le médecin ni le
patient ne savent si ce qui a été
injecté était le placebo ou le vaccin on
laisse ensuite chaque vente et à
reprendre sa vie normale
enfin je veux dire sa vie en période
commis 19 puis à chaque fois qu'un
volontaire développent des symptômes ou
et testé positif aux comédies 19
on les comptabilise au fil des mois qui
suivent on recense ainsi les volontaires
de l'essai clinique qui ont été testées
positives
on peut alors tracé un graff qui donne
le nombre de cas positifs recensés au
cours du temps si la courbe qui
correspond au groupe contrôle augmentent
beaucoup plus vite que celle qui
correspond groupe test c'est que le
vaccin a certainement aidé à protéger
les individus du groupe quelle est
l'efficacité du vaccin est alors obtenu
en divisant à une date donnée
le nombre de cas positifs du groupe
placebo par le nombre de cas positifs au
total dans les groupes placebo et groupe
tests c'est ainsi que l'efficacité des
vaccins fils eur puis à une tech d'un
côté et moderna de l'autre ont été
estimés à hauteur d'environ 95% et ça
c'est vraiment une excellente nouvelle
alors il faut noter qu'on teste l'a
finalement la protection du vaccin
contre le fait d'être en gros positif ou
que vider 19 mais ceci n'est pas la
seule mesure d'efficacité du vaccin qui
mérite d'être étudié notre mesure
importante d'efficacité et celle de la
protection contre les cas sévères
notamment pour les populations à risque
il semble qu'on est là encore
d'excellentes nouvelles de ce côté lors
des essais cliniques de modern a en
particulier aucun sujet vacciner non
ensuite subi deux cas graves de convives
19 voilà qui suggèrent qu'il pourrait
être extrêmement bénéfique de fournir ce
vaccin aux individus à risque en
particulier même s'il faudra bien sûr
suivre avec soin l'état de tels vacciner
noter en particulier que les vaccins bel
et bien été testé sur des sujets avec
des profils divers et variés y compris
par exemple des personnes âgées
alors côté effets secondaires comme tout
vaccin les vaccins de pfizer et moderna
provoque des douleurs des maux de tête
ainsi que des coups de chaud des coups
de froid de la fatigue et possiblement
des diarrhées notez toutefois que à
l'exception de la douleur dans le site
d'injection beaucoup de ces effets
secondaires apparaissent aussi dans le
groupe placebo quoique dans des
proportions souvent un peu moins
ces symptômes peuvent même être intense
pour quelques personnes vaccinées
cependant pour tous les cas observé
jusque là ces effets secondaires ne dure
pas il ne semble pas dangereux
sachant que des millions de doses ont
été injectés à ce jour ceci montre que
les risques d'effets secondaires très
très graves sont nécessairement moins
probable que un sur un million ce qui
rend les vaccins beaucoup moins
dangereux que locaux vides et 19
lui-même
même si bien sûr il convient de
continuer à surveiller la santé des
personnes vaccinées alors qu'en est il
maintenant de la protection à long terme
du vaccin
et bien malheureusement aucune donnée
direct n'est disponible
tout simplement car cela ne fait
seulement qu'un an qu'une vivent avec
locaux vides 10,9 la durabilité de
l'immunité et la variabilité d'un
individu à l'autre sens encore très
incertaine même si certaines données
semblent encourageantes plus de données
plus fiables qui viendront au fur et à
mesure devrait toutefois nous permettre
de réduire ces incertitudes
au fil des mois et des années à venir
une autre préoccupation est celle de la
protection du vaccin contre la
contagiosité
idéalement le vaccin devrait également
nous empêcher de diffuser le virus ce
qui permettrait de enfin mettre fin à
toutes les mesures de gestes barrières
de distanciation physique et de couvre
feu malheureusement là encore faute de
données l'incertitude est encore grande
néanmoins l'incertitude sur la
protection ne signifie pas l'absence de
protection il est même loin d'être
improbable que les vaccins à arn offre
au moins une protection partielle contre
la contagiosité ce qui sera déjà très
utiles pour réduire le taux de
reproduction effectif
rt et le ramener en dessous de 1 et pour
rappel c'est vraiment de ce taux de
reproduction effectif que le futur
dépend pour l'instant donc l'incertitude
est encore grande car on manque de
données fiables à ce sujet et ce n'est
pas étonnant car ces données fiables
sont très longues et difficiles à
collecter cet article de wired note
toutefois que l'opacité de données des
entreprises est très problématique et
qu'il faudrait songer à exiger beaucoup
plus de transparence de leur part enfin
on peut se demander si le vaccin nous
protège les mutations du virus comme la
mutation qui a été identifiée au royaume
uni d'après différents experts dont
l'immunologue anthony facci ou la verte
sinologue marie paule kieny
le vaccin sera très probablement
efficace contre la mutation au royaume
uni mais il demeure un léger risque
qu'ils le soient peut-être moins contre
de potentielles mutation futur est donc
très hypothétique du virus bref les
données sur les vaccins jusque là sont
très prometteuses
nous allons aussi extrêmement incomplète
il demeure beaucoup d'incertitudes mais
alors face à cette incertitude
faut-il s'abstenir d'agir eh bien il
reviendra en conclusion de cette vidéo
mais en bref comme on l'a vu dans la
série surprise il faut surtout se lancer
dans une analyse risque/bénéfice qui
dans ce cas me semble très largement
penché vers la vaccination de masse même
dans le cas où cette vaccination de
masse ne résoudrait pas nécessairement
tout tout de suite
elle sait emmener au moins largement
préférable à l'alternative qui semble
nous contraindre à davantage de mesures
contraignantes en terme de distanciation
physique et de restriction des libertés
de circulation
pour mieux comprendre les risques de la
vaccination il est utile de comprendre
un peu mieux le fonctionnement des
vaccins en général dont on a déjà parlé
dans l'épisode 10 et de la technologie
des vaccins à arn messagers en
particulier sur laquelle reposent les
vaccins fille soeur et modern a alors ne
rentrera pas du tout dans toutes les
subtilités des vaccins dans cette vidéo
parce que achetés avec des c'est
compliqué et parce que je vous prépare
une autre vidéo qui entrera un peu plus
son certains détails techniques et
également parce que bon il ya plein de
détails biologique que je ne comprends
pas du tout à titre personnel ceci dit
le principe global des vaccins à arn et
à la fois simple et extrêmement
ingénieux
il consiste à injecter quelques millions
de milliards de brindas arn messager
dans votre corps et on ajoute parfois
cela des adjuvants pour stimuler la
réaction immunitaire mais cela n'a pas
été nécessaire dans les vaccins fille
soeur et moderna qui ne contiennent donc
pas d'adjuvant grâce ensuite à des
astuces d'ingéniérie biomédicale
absolument remarquable c'est brindas et
rennes vont ensuite entrer dans les
cellules de notre corps n'est pas dans
les noyaux des cellules où se trouve la
dn nos cellules vont alors lierse et
brindas et rennes comme s'il s'agissait
d' instructions émises par l'adn ce qui
va les amener à produire des protéines
associées
et justement dans le cas des vaccins
pisseurs et moderna les protéines ainsi
produites sont les protéines dites spike
du virus sarr skov deux responsables du
comité 19
ces protéines sont ensuite acheminés à
l'extérieur de nos cellules et notre
système immunitaire valor s'activer pour
apprendre à identifier et neutraliser
rapidement ces protéines spike de façon
cruciale des composantes de notre
système immunitaire vont garder en
mémoire commence active et efficacement
contre ces protéines spike si plus tard
on est effectivement infectés par des
virus sarr skov de notre système
immunitaire va s'activer plus rapidement
pour inhiber efficacement les spike du
virus ce qui empêchera le virus
d'infiltrer nos cellules
ces virus ne pourront alors pas à quai
les mécanismes de nos cellules pour se
multiplier
ils seront aussi et surtout attaqué et
détruit par notre système immunitaire
notre corps pourra alors contenir la
propagation du virus sans confinement
enfin je veux dire sans souffrir
le gros avantage les vaccins à rnc que
ces vaccins sont beaucoup plus rapides à
développer et à produire en grande
quantité
voilà qui a permis de les tester et de
les rendre disponibles rapidement mais
aussi de rapidement mettre en place des
chaînes de production capable de
produire des milliards de doses en un an
l'autre point critique c'est
l'efficacité d'environ 95% de ces
vaccins ou plutôt d'après la publication
de twitter avec crédence 95 %
l'efficacité de leurs vaccins est entre
90 % et 98 %
et oui la publication parle bien
d'intervalle de crédence puisqu'elle
savait sur une analyse bayésienne qui
est d'ailleurs en gros la même que celle
utilisée par pierre simon laplace la
place dans le premier article buy vient
de l'histoire des sciences notamment
pour résoudre le fameux problème de
l'induction de kew donc ça j'en parlerai
mais dans la série sur bex comme j'en ai
parlé dans une autre vidéo un
déploiement précipité de vaccins avec
une moindre efficacité s'accompagne et
de risques importants de bâclage grâce
au succès fantastique des vaccins à arn
cette préoccupation est évacuée et j'en
ai donc profité pour mettre cette vidéo
en ont répertorié
il ya toutefois des inconvénients
également le plus gros inconvénient des
vaccins à arn c'est que la rn se dégrade
rapidement à température ambiante pour
être préservé les vaccins à arn doivent
être conservés à très faible température
moins 70 degrés celsius pour peter et
-20 degrés celsius pour modern art ainsi
pour distribuer les vaccins arn aux
quatre coins du monde des chaîne
logistique sophistiquée avec des supers
congélateur doivent être mises en place
et toutes les régions du monde ne
pourront pas être servi aussi facilement
les unes que les autres
un autre inconvénient de ces vaccins et
la nécessité d'une double dose autrement
dit les personnes vaccinées doivent être
vaccinés une première fois pour venir se
faire vacciner
puis revenir se faire vacciner quelques
semaines plus tard cela augmente la
complexité logistique de la vaccination
de masse et d'ailleurs certains
proposent de s'infliger cette chaîne
logistique et de vacciner davantage de
personnes en ne donnant qu'une seule
dose par patient et ça c'est soulever
encore plus de questions qu'ils sortent
complètement du cadre de cette vidéo et
pour lequel je n'ai absolument pas l'
expertise pour donner un avis informé
par ailleurs les vaccins arn demeure une
technologie relativement nouvelle chez
les humains même s'ils ont déjà beaucoup
été utilisé pour des besoins vétérinaire
ceci étant dit on comprend bien les
mécanismes biologiques clé en jeu en
particulier on comprend très bien que la
rn messager se dégrade sans se
multiplier dans notre corps ce qui
garantit que la production des protéines
spike
finira par s'arrêter par ailleurs qu'on
explique tania lui dans ce billet de
blog les risques de modification de
l'adn par le vaccin arn sont extrêmement
négligeable notamment par rapport aux
risques du coc vis d'eux mêmes néanmoins
comme on l'a vu il demeure des
incertitudes importantes autour des
vaccins à arn comme la protection à long
terme l'effet sur la contagiosité et la
robustesse ou mutations ces
inconvénients et ces incertitudes font
qu'il demeure sans doute important de
suivre avec attention les personnes
vaccinées et surtout de poursuivre la
recherche sur des vaccins alternatif qui
pourrait être plus facile à distribuer
et réduire davantage la contagiosité du
coc vide 19
comme on l'a vu donc il reste plusieurs
incertitudes vis-à-vis des vaccins à arn
dans les mois à venir de nombreuses
nouvelles données vont certainement
grandement réduire ces incertitudes
néanmoins l'incertitude n'a pas de
raison de nous contraindre à l'inaction
loin de là pour déterminer que faire
malgré l'incertitude de médecine nous
invite à effectuer une analyse
risque/bénéfice ou pour parler dans un
langage bayésiens une analyse
contractuels autrement dit plutôt que de
se demander si le vaccin offre toutes
les garanties qu'on aimerait avoir
l'analyse contrat factuel nous pousse à
imaginer les conséquences probables
d'une promotion et d'une adoption
massive des vaccins arn par opposition
aux conséquences probables de l'absence
d'une telle promotion et adoption
massive
c'est 80% de la population se fait
vacciner et si vous vous faites vacciner
quelles en seraient les conséquences
probables et surtout si seulement 20% de
la population se fait vacciner
et si vous ne vous faites pas vacciner
quelles en seraient les conséquences
probables comment évoluerait alors les
nombres de cas d'hospitalisation et de
décès du co vite des dix neuf dans
chacun de ces d'oka et devra-t-on alors
ce qu'on finit régulièrement restés
distants de nos amis et nos proches et
prêter attention aux gestes barrières
j'espère vous avoir convaincus que même
s'il n'y a pas de garantie de retrouver
une vie normale
même en cas de vaccination de masse les
reste néanmoins très largement probable
que les choses iront alors nettement
mieux pour vous et pour toute la
population une fois qu'une fraction
importante de cette population sera
vaccinée